Guten morgen linus.
Guten morgen tim.
Was hast du gehört der boris hat jetzt auch corona.
Da müssen wir aber jetzt daumen drücken.
Logbuch netzpolitik nummer dreihundertsiebenunddreißig vom siebenundzwanzigsten märz zweitausend,
rund zwanzig direkt aus der meta quarantäne wir sind alle schön weg gespeichert hier im internet und kommen aber trotzdem direkt zu euch ins hörgerät wie immer stimmt's linos.
Hat sich doch nichts verändert.
Es hat sich nichts geändert wir als nerds sitzen ja sowieso den ganzen tag nur in der bude insofern,
kommen wir mit den situationen sehr gut klar ist überhaupt nicht schlimm hier in der wohnung ich habe mich auch schon verletzt ja,
homeoffice ist gefährlich.
Die meisten unfälle passieren im haushalt ne.
Ja ich habe mir du kennst das ja wenn man sich den kleinen zeh stößt und dann denkt man hat sich den gebrochen.
Ja kenne ich.
Kennst du das auch wenn man sich den wirklich gebrochen hat.
Bisher bin ich gott sei dank verschont geblieben bist du sicher.
Ich bin nicht sicher weil ich traue mich natürlich jetzt nicht ins krankenhaus ne.
Das kannst du vergessen der steht dann ab das sieht bestimmt lustig aus dann.
Ja der wird jetzt hier ich muss mal gucken es ist auf jeden fall erstaunlich welche tücken des home-office birgt und.
Wir erdulden die maßnahmen noch und ich denke,
es rappelt aber langsam im karton ja die stimmen werden natürlich auch ungeduldiger und lauter und wir werden uns noch mal mit dem thema der,
grundrechtseinschränkungen in der nächsten sendung auseinandersetzen ich habe aber persönlich so ein.
In meiner corona so eine zeit durchgemacht.
In der ich anfangs so keinerlei risiko empfinden hatte irgendwie von januar februar sprechen,
dann mir,
primäre sorgen um das um infektion und tote gemacht habe und jetzt so in letzter zeit fast die sorge um dass die wirtschaftliche entwicklung,
im freundeskreis schwerer wirkt wiegt.
Und aus diesem grund möchten wir uns heute mal mit den.
Allgemein wirtschaftlichen folgen der korona krise auseinandersetzen und da meine,
kapazitäten in diesem bereich sehr beschränkt sind haben wir uns dafür daniel kröger in die sendung eingeladen daniel ist fondsmanager in frankfurt.
Und daniel du hast dich mich ganz ehrlich du hast dich ja angeboten in die sendung zu kommen wieso wieso hältst du dich für qualifiziert ist ja schon ein bisschen dreist auch einfach zu sagen hör mal ich kann euch das erklären.
Erstmal sagen wir mal hallo daniel herzlich willkommen dass du dabei bist.
Hallo timm hallo linus.
Herzlich willkommen.
Ja vielen dank.
Na gut also warum fühle ich mich berufen und da warum kenne ich mich aus fondsmanager sein heißt geld anderer leute zu verwalten also sprich natürlich andere leute und auch mein eigenes geld und das mache ich jetzt mittlerweile seit zwanzig jahren,
das mit erfolg und ich glaube zumindest einzuordnen was nun der börsencrash bedeutet was,
auswirkungen von hilfspakete sind gesellschaftliche aspekte ich denke ja das kann ich sicherlich gut erklären und auch da die fragen auf eurer seite beantworten.
Also ich würde sagen wir fangen mit dem feedback trotzdem noch kurz an aber daniel bevor wir das vergessen du hast gesagt wir müssen eine warnung vorwegschicken um rechtlich auf der sicheren seite zu sein wir geben hier keine investitions,
beratung sondern nur eine absolut unqualifizierte einschätzung der wirtschaftlichen lage der nation.
Nicht dass wir wie julian assange irgendwo demnächst in der botschaft gefangen sind oder so.
Nee,
okay kommen wir zum feedback es gab viel feedback ich habe mal hier was rausgesucht was ich ganz gehässige dem tim unter die nase reiben möchte nämlich den kommentar vom trocken häuptling,
der uns über den sinn und unsinn des lüften von zimmern aufklärt man lüftet die zimmer regelmäßig um feuchtigkeit heraus zu lassen diese entsteht beim ausatmen kochen waschen blumen gießen,
künstlicher luftbefeuchter aquarien verdunstung,
und sonstige zeug feuchtigkeit ist hauptursache für die ausbreitung von schimmelpilzen helfen bakterien und eben auch aktivierungsgruppe lage für viren.
Haltet also eure zimmer trocken und luftig und er merkt noch an tim ist ein guter aber er weiß leider längst nicht alles.
Ganz im gegensatz zu mir.
Du bist kein guter oder was.
Stefan hat.
Sich gefreut über die dreihundertvier in der wir ein bisschen über depressionen in,
isolation und social distanz und home-office gesprochen haben,
und er hat sogar daraus einen kleinen text gemacht mit erinnerung wo das nochmal zusammengefasst ist den link haben wir in den shownotes hat mich sehr gefreut und da habe ich ja,
denke ich mal durchaus ein thema früh genug angeschnitten sodass ich hoffe dass einige menschen sich da tatsächlich irgendwie einen gewinn daraus ziehen konnten.
Und das hilft weil ich zumindest merke dass ich das mich,
zu diesem aktivitäts aufbau bewegung und so weiter jetzt durchaus versuche zu zwingen was natürlich jetzt durch den diesen c ein bisschen schwieriger wird.
Dann gab es noch feedback,
privater natur hallo linus ich habe heute für die klasse meiner achtjährigen tochter in virtuelles klassenzimmer über deinen server eingerichtet hat super geklappt und macht die isolation für kids eltern und lehrerinnen schon ein ganzes stück erträglicher,
mein längst überfälligen dauerauftrag für metaebene logbuch netzpolitik habe ich heute auch endlich eingerichtet danke für alles was ihr tut,
ja vielen herzlichen dank für dieses feedback und danke für die last auf dem server es gibt auch andere möchte ich an der stelle nochmal sagen,
ich habe heute schon ein etwas aufgeregtes telefonat geführt wir werden da die serverkapazitäten noch ein bisschen hochschrauben.
Ich habe ja auch noch einige andere server im angebot aber ich kann nur empfehlen solche server selber einzurichten und nur empfehlen die last der so ein bisschen zu verteilen und.
Ich denke dass auch langsam setzt sich das durch dass leute sich immer besser auf solche videokonferenzen,
vorbereiten das heißt eventuell schaffen wir es noch vorm zusammenbruch des finanzsystems dass man in eine videokonferenz gehen kann,
ohne in der ersten viertelstunde einen nervenzusammenbruch zu erleiden ich bin da guter dinge.
Also ich weiß nicht videokonferenzen ist für mich eine quelle für nervenzusammenbrüche.
Heute gab es dann eine schöne statistik vom blumenberg wieviel pro minute denn verbraucht er für den einzelnen anbietern google hangouts war da mit fünfzehn pro minute da der spitzenreiter.
Ok und was sind die besten also was sind die schmalste schmalspur videokonferenz.
Facetime ist tatsächlich am besten.
Facetime ist am besten.
Am besten im sinne von das ja am wenigsten bandbreite pro verbindung brauchen oder wie.
Exakt her genau.
Ja das überrascht mich nicht weil die glaube ich die modernsten kodex verwenden mit zweihundertfünfundsechzig.
Whatsapp war so in der mitte und skype zoom kam dann schon da an google hangouts ran.
Kam jetzt auch vor.
Leider nein ich glaube plumper kennt sowas nicht.
Das fällt dann bestenfalls so unter rtc oder sowas das wird schwierig zu kategorisieren sein.
Ja dann lass uns doch mal ein bisschen über wirtschaft reden das ist ja durchaus ein thema wie linus schon eingeleitet hat ist die
große kontakt ausgangssperre das schließen der ganzen läden natürlich für diverse branchen und die wirtschaft als solche,
ein ziemlich harter schlag manche sind da natürlich extrem betroffen,
restaurants alles versucht kulturell im angebot ist da findet quasi der totalausfall,
andere können irgendwie so halbwegs weiterarbeiten wenn gleich mit einschränkungen stichwort homeoffice das ist natürlich auch nicht in jeder branche möglich
andere wiederum,
haben auch durchaus extreme nachfrage lieferdienste aller art ich glaube auch so für supermarkt bringen dienste etcetera ist das wahrscheinlich der durchbruch auf denen sie schon längere zeit gewartet haben,
könnte man die liste jetzt noch beliebig lange fortführen das führt jetzt allerdings zu nix die frage ist natürlich nur,
worauf muss man sich jetzt eigentlich einstellen und wie ist diese auswirkung auf die gesamtwirtschaft an sich einzuschätzen,
vielleicht kannst du erstmal so ein bisschen aus deiner perspektive erzählen was ist eigentlich also jetzt sozusagen mit der wirtschaftsboom wille,
was ist eigentlich konkret bisher passiert was was was für ereignisse müsste man jetzt überhaupt erstmal zur kenntnis nehmen um das betrachten zu können.
Ja gut im grunde genommen ist ja erstmal ein also abgesehen natürlich davon dass wir irgendwie virus haben und unmenschen sterben was was schlimm genug ist was natürlich eine börse immer passiert ist dass aktienkurse zukünftige dinge vorwegnehmen darum geht es ja meistens,
was wir.
In jeglicher hinsicht sammelt sich viele superlative erreicht sowohl der kursverfall in aktienmärkten war noch nie in dieser dramatik also dramatik meine ich just in dieser schärfe also von jetzt auf gleich dieser extreme absturz,
das war noch nie in dieser form gewesen natürlich wirtschaftlich gab es das auch noch nie dass eine wirtschaft ja im grunde genommen von hundert auf auf null runter gefahren wurde und.
So mal ein drittel dieser welt befindet sich gerade auf dem nullpunkt was wirtschaftliche leistung angeht und das hat natürlich auswirkung auf die unternehmen klar bin ich natürlich kein,
golf oder was auch immer oder ein bmw produziere den kann ich dir nicht verkaufen auf der anderen seite gibt's auch niemanden der gerade vielleicht geld hat weil nämlich keins verdient um sich dieses auto halt zu kaufen und die,
frage die daraus resultiert ist natürlich wann ist das beendet wir überbrücken wir das ganze mit was für geldern und wie sieht die erholung danach aus haben wir so eine art v-förmigen erholung also,
drei vier monate ist alles im tiefpunkt und danach geht's genauso wieder nach oben weiter förmige entwicklung ist das so die eine seite was.
Bedeuten die ganzen hilfspakete die wir haben was unglaubliches geld ist was da bereitgestellt wird insbesondere muss man sich auch mal im auge behalten natürlich wesentlich mehr als noch zur finanzkrise zweitausendacht und wir dachten schon das wäre der größte krise die wir jemals,
erlebt haben,
und es bringt natürlich viele gesellschaftliche faktoren mit sich insbesondere natürlich auch politische haben wir wieder die ganze diskussion über die einheit der eu wird sie irgendwie das aushalten können,
natürlich auch in amerika damit ich auch viele diskussionen haben jetzt auch gerade bei der abstimmung dann jetzt gesehen im senat die demokraten im mitreden wollen und so weiter.
Lass uns mal erstmal so eine so eine kleine timeline machen was es eigentlich passiert so ne also wir haben ja jetzt im prinzip und die frage ist schaut man sich das jetzt generell global an oder ist es vielleicht erstmal sinnvoll sich auf deutschland zu beschränken.
Also das betrifft ja alle länder so also global schon das heißt wir haben erlebt dass wir in den letzten zwei wochen circa fünfundzwanzig millionen an us-dollar also in westerland nominiert vernichtet haben an den börsen,
gut jetzt den letzten zweiter handelstagen haben wir gesehen dass die märkte sich wieder ein drittel erholt haben aber das ist zumindest erstmal die ausgangslage also das was passiert ist dass die leute in völliger panik draußen umherlaufen also ich meinte jetzt auf der wirtschaft seite.
Was natürlich zur folge hat wenn jemand in panik ist klar dann denkt er nicht mehr rationalen drückt seinen verkaufs- das passiert auf der einen seite.
Aber was heißt was heißt denn dann billionen sind vernichtet worden also wessen.
Wessen billionen sind also was ist denn passiert also corona kam deutschland macht den shutdown italien war im prinzip also eigentlich kam ja erstmal
china so das hat uns erstmal nicht so unmittelbar betroffen man dachte das wäre auch alles noch lokal dann ist es in italien eigentlich losgegangen
dieser komplett look down des gesamten landes oder zumindest der wirtschaftlichen des wirtschaftlichen zentrums des landes stattgefunden hat dann haben wir es in österreich deutschland etcetera mittlerweile fast überall gehabt
das hat dann welche unmittelbare auswirkungen auf die börse gehabt alle leute denken sich so krise irgendwie jetzt verkaufe ich meine aktien oder was.
Exakt also wenn wir nochmal bei dem punkt anfangen was du sagst ist china das war ja so mal ende des jahres da jeder gedacht wie du richtig sagst ist so ein bisschen lokal die börse hat ja gar nicht darauf reagiert
wenn du mit dem unternehmen schon gesprochen hast das war sicher da mal täglich tue damals schon gemerkt hier und da gibt's so ein paar engpässe im in den in den lieferketten gerade auf der auf der chip seite wenn man mit apple gesprochen hat et cetera,
das konnte man aber alles noch relativ gut handeln,
dann haben wir es natürlich alles seinen verlauf klar wir haben diese e-funktionen entwicklung und das haben sich die leute überrascht meiner meinung nach auch dass viele leute nicht verstehen was eine funktion ist aber das habe ich ein anderes thema und,
börsenwert vernichtet heiß im grunde genommen so eine apple hat in einer marktkapitalisierung von von einer billion,
das heißt also der aktienkurs mal die ausgegebenen aktien ergibt den wert eines unternehmens und wenn ich jetzt sage fünfundzwanzig millionen wurden vernichtet dann über den gesamten markt heißt es der aktienkurs ist in dem gegenwert verfallen das geld ist.
In dem sinne weg oder vernichtet.
Ja gut aber wem fehlt es das fehlt ja nicht apple
also apple hat ja die aktien verkauft und apple hat sie jetzt in diesem fall auch nicht gekauft also das geld was sie aber aus dem verkauf von aktien mal eingenommen haben dass das das haben sie ja im prinzip immer noch.
Es ist ein nullsummenspiel im im endeffekt im endeffekt das richtig irgendjemand hat natürlich verluste gemacht irgendjemand hat auf der anderen seite natürlich gewinne gemacht sondern man sich das mal anschaut.
Ist es so dass es gibt aktienfonds so welche in der art wie ich sie manager also sprich,
menschen geben uns geld zur verfügung dahinter steht eine gewisse strategie und für die strategie stehen wir und kaufen aktien also sprich mein job ist,
wir haben relativ konzentriertes portfolio so dreißig aktien im portfolio.
Das heißt ich muss mich nicht relativ tief mit dem unternehmen befassen also reise viel um die welt und mit unternehmen vor ort anzugucken um zu verstehen natürlich erstmal an was macht das unternehmen und,
er ist vielleicht ein guter punkt und zu verstehen was unternehmen wert ist sind ja zwei dinge einerseits sagt man der börsenkurs apple ist irgendwo weiß ich nicht zweihundertfünfzig dollar wert an meine aufgabe ist ja herauszufinden ist es unter umständen mehrwert ansonsten macht's ja keinen sinn es unternehmen zu kaufen.
Das geht natürlich nur dann wenn ich präzise schaffe auf sicht sag mal das ist mindestens eine devise auf drei jahren zu kalkulieren wie sich wie sich gewisse dinge entwickeln also sprich.
Einfach jetzt erstmal gesprochen umsatz und und der gewinn,
und wenn ich das gut prognostizieren kann dann kann ich ja ausrechnen was das pro aktie bedeutet und weiß ob apple billig oder teuer ist,
du darfst jetzt mal grob gesprochen dafür geben die leute mir geld oder uns geld um das natürlich mit einer gewissen renditeerwartung pro jahr das geld bei uns anzulegen.
Nur zwischen uns diesen sommer originären aktienfonds gibt's nämlich auch gewisse hedgefonds die das ganze natürlich irgendwie hebel mit derivaten und das ist genau der punkt was wir erlebt haben dass wir.
Eine gewisse hedgefonds haben wir ein bisschen sich auf die einzelnen strategien eingehen aber die auf jeden fall immense summen bewegen mit mit derivaten also sprich mit future kontrakt also das heißt ich kann.
Ja gewisse zukunftswelt heute schon handeln und das sogar noch gehebelt,
im vergleich zu dem was eigentlich wirklich auf diesem planeten an an gegenwert eigentlich da ist und wenn ich das natürlich dramatisch von heute auf gleich jetzt verkaufe dann habe ich diese gegenbewegung nach unten da sprechen wir entsprechend von millionen millionen hat entschuldigung.
Diese front sind jetzt immer schon so ein problem gewesen ne also das ist ja sozusagen nichts nicht nichts neues an der stelle.
Nichts neues das stimmt nur die schärfe ist tatsächlich neu also es ist ja auch zum teil auch im computer geschrieben das heißt wenn du gewisse verlust schwellen erreichst dann triggert das den computer und der sagt oh jetzt muss ich aber verkaufen,
du hast natürlich also unsere kunden sind unter anderem klar privatinvestoren also jeder kann zur sparkasse gehen unseren vorn kaufen auf der einen seite auf der anderen seite sind es natürlich auch kirchen stiftungen,
dir auch ein gewisses risiko budget haben,
und wenn die jetzt sehen oh ich bin dieses jahr bei minus zehn prozent dann haben die die devise zum beispiel komplett ihr geld darzustellen also es triggert halt auch automatisch verkäufe und das führt natürlich auch zu dieser schärfe und die chance nutzen natürlich auch sowas aus.
Wie gelingt es denen das auszunutzen also die der mir.
Es wäre jetzt schon noch so die frage da wird jetzt ok es wird wert vernichtet wert ist erstmal nur die hoffnung dass es diesem unternehmen noch gut geht ja oder dass dass man diese,
alle kaufen quasi in erwartung dass es in zukunft nochmal mehr wert sein würde ja aber.
Wenn jetzt mal so ein starker kursrutsch ist den die verluste streicheln ja nur die ein die noch verkaufen.
Also in meinem fond habe ich nichts verkauft das heißt die verluste die jetzt dort stehen stehen natürlich erstmal nur auf dem papier.
Sind noch nicht realisiert.
Genau exakt.
Werde ich aber auch nicht also das ist ja genau der unterschied die leute haben wir die verkaufen müssen beziehungsweise die in panik sind die haben natürlich verkaufen auch diese verluste realisiert.
Ich sage aber für mich ich weiß für mich selber was das unternehmen wert ist und haben durch den zeithorizont warum soll ich das jetzt verkaufen es macht komisch gar keinen sinn ich glaube an meinem haus hat folgendes gedankenexperiment machen.
Wenn für heute die börsen für fünf jahre zu wehren würde ich heute aktien kaufen ja oder nein und die unternehmen würden genauso ab irgendeinem zeitpunkt weitermachen so die frage muss man sich halt beantworten.
Und wenn ich die mit ja beantworte da macht er sich keinen sinn aktien zu verkaufen sondern vielleicht eine umständen sogar zu kaufen.
Die einzige frage die man sich stellt ist natürlich wie lange dauert die krise und wie tief wird die börsenkurs fallen und je länger die krise dauert desto weniger umsatz wird natürlich unter umständen einen apple machen weil es vielleicht noch gar nicht mehr so sehr betroffen sondern,
wirklich vielleicht leute nehmen kinobetreiber der umsatz wird natürlich nie wiederkommen wenn ich jetzt auch noch als und als kinobetreiber viele schulden habe dann gehe ich im worst case pleite.
Um natürlich daran hängt in vielen unternehmen mitarbeiter die jetzt,
kurzarbeit beantragen müssen beziehungsweise arbeitslos sind die haben auch kein geld in der tasche die werden jetzt also sie können jetzt gerade eh nichts kaufen aber selbst wenn die krise vorbei wäre,
wenn sie nicht als erstes sich jetzt wieder ein neues iphone kaufen und wir erstmal gucken dass ihre kosten beisammen halten und sie werden fertig im teurem supermarkt gehen sondern vielleicht nur beim discounter und sich erstmal billiges essen kaufen weil sie sagen ich muss mein mann mein geld beisammen halten.
Und das ist natürlich schlecht für die wirtschaft.
Hast du du setzt dich in deinem fonds wahrscheinlich mit großen unternehmen auseinander oder wie würdest du.
Die lage sehen in so vielen kleinen unternehmen also was ich jetzt so beobachte.
Ob apple jetzt mal ein paar iphones verkauft oder nicht ist so eine sache das rettungspaket was ja jetzt hier in den
verschiedenen ländern bundesländern und staaten irgendwie stattfindet
scheint aber vermutlich eher auch auf die noch abzielen zu wollen die jetzt dies jetzt irgendwie schneller erwischt ne gastronomen
scheint ja zum beispiel eine hardcore betroffene gruppe zu sein den letztendlich jetzt der geschäftsbetrieb untersagt wurde.
Der frau ist breit gestreut also nochmal kleine unternehmen glaub gastros jetzt nicht dabei nein aber klar klein und groß ja.
Wie denkt wie ist so deine auffassung davon,
wie in einer solchen situation von einer regierung oder von einer bank oder zentralbank oder weber von denen da oben ja,
sinnvoll reagiert wird ja es gibt ja unterschiedliche auffassungen davon wie mit dieser situation umzugehen ist eine habe ich ja in der letzten sendung geäußert nämlich,
kapitalertragsteuer werden einfach ausgeschaltet.
Und das ist das worauf man im zweifelsfall am längsten verzichten kann weil man das nicht mit seiner eigenen arbeit schafft insofern würde ich sagen,
vermieter nehmen keine mieten mehr ein.
Das was ihnen dabei wenn sie das objekt was sie dort vermieten irgendwie noch mit krediten finanziert haben dann nehmen die entsprechenden banken,
keine zinsen mehr ein und die entsprechend und die,
zahlung rückzahlung der kredite wird ebenso gestundet wie die miete und wir lassen einfach den größten teil,
dieses wirtschaftsgeschehen tatsächlich auch stehen weil meine argumentation wenn jetzt irgendwie die nagelstudios und die,
kneipen und die freelancer und so alle ein wirtschaftlichen stillstand haben warum soll dann ausgerechnet der markt für mieten,
weiterlaufen interessanterweise wird diese radikale ansicht ja seit kurzem geteilt von so,
kommunisten wie adidas und h und m ja,
die nehme ich jetzt auch bekannt gegeben haben für unsere mehreren hundert filialen in der bundesrepublik deutschland rufen wir jetzt den besetzungen zustand aus ja,
das ist unser haus die häuser denen die sachen drin verkaufen und wir werden jetzt einfach hier drin bleiben und ohne miete zu zahlen.
Warum wäre das ein problem.
Ja gut ich meine.
Kapitalertragsteuer damit geld zu erwirtschaften ist ja per se erstmal nichts schlimmes sondern ich meine das geld was du irgendwo erstmal im umlauf bringt um damit geld zu verdienen hast du ja auch vorher mit deiner,
körperlichen also wenn es nicht gerade gehabt hast oder sowas ja auch mit körperlicher arbeit oder wie auch immer quasi erworben darauf steuern bezahlt ist immer geld ist was überbleibt also per se ist ja erstmal nichts schlimmes,
so wenn ich jetzt irgendwie über ein haus habe was ich gebaut habe und habe es vermietet um damit vielleicht mal eine rente zu finanzieren beziehungsweise aufzustocken wäre es natürlich für den rentner schlecht.
Ja das ist dann halt sehr bedauerlich auf jeden fall für den rentner,
jetzt ist das natürlich genauso bedauerlich für leute die das geld genommen haben und gesagt haben ich baue eine kneipe auf und miete zum zwecke des aufbaus dieser kneipe eine,
eine ecke an eine häuser ecke an.
Und jetzt kommt der staat hin und sagt okay deine kneipe darfst du jetzt nicht mehr öffnen muss auf alle einnahmen verzichten wieso wäre das denn in dem falle in ordnung und in dem anderen nicht.
Ich glaube ich würde es gar nicht miteinander vergleichen ich glaube es ist auch glaube ich nicht hundertprozentig so wie du sagst ich weiß dass es hier in hessen so ist dass man in der lage ist seine miete um zwanzig prozent zu kürzen die der vermieter dann vom staat wieder erstattet bekommt,
als beispiel.
Und du kannst dir auf der anderen seite auch deine miete stunden aber ich glaube du kannst mit dem vermieter reden und ich kenne es tatsächlich auch hier von vielen gastro kollegen in frankfurt dass auch da selbst die vermieter von alleine auf die zugegangen und haben gesagt hier haben wir
die nächsten vier monate kannst du die miete aussetzen und danach muss es natürlich zurückzahlen also ich glaube schon dass es irgendwie gleich verteilt ist.
Ich würde es nicht entweder oder mit in diese diskussion reinpacken.
Also die frage ist ist es offenbar so dass diese wirtschaft nicht pause machen kann das wäre ja eigentlich sehr.
Also man könnte ja eigentlich auch sagen du hast ja gerade auch schon gesagt so handelt stopp ja man könnte auch sagen okay,
wir setzen jetzt alles aus und wir verbieten den handel von aktien jeder muss darauf sitzen bleiben
es es darf jetzt keiner mehr verkaufen ja klar das geht natürlich nicht wird weiter würde weiter gemacht werden aber warum machen wir überhaupt diese kursschwankungen mit wenn doch eigentlich klar ist dass es.
Weitergehen wird ne also es ist würde jetzt vorsichtig sagen.
Wenn man sich heute irgend ein etf kauft ist es relativ sicher dass der innerhalb von fünf jahren einen höheren wert haben wird wenn ich innerhalb von zehn oder fünfzehn.
Bin ich bei dir.
Warum sagen wir dann nicht wenn das wenn das gesamte wirtschaftliche geschehen jetzt einfach mal zum erliegen kommt dass wir dann nicht auch wirklich pause machen pause machen pause okay.
Also weil es kommt ja offenbar immer nur ein teil des wirtschaftlichen lebens zum erliegen und dieser teil wird dann irgendwie ruiniert ja also in berlin ist es jetzt tatsächlich,
du hast ja gerade im vorgespräch auch gesagt du hast deinen bekanntenkreis halt leute die auch beispielsweise in der gastronomie tätig sind oder im einzelhandel.
Den geht nach kürzester zeit da die puste aus ne und diese.
Es gibt eine andere den geht nicht die puste aus zum beispiel deren vermietern den geht die puste erstmal so schnell nicht aus.
Wie ist jetzt kluges staatliches handeln möglich um.
Ja vielleicht auch diesen schaden entweder gleichmäßig zu verteilen oder gleichmäßig abzuwenden.
Also punkt eins börse schließen es wird natürlich jetzt tatsächlich auch diskutiert diesen fall gab es schon mal unter anderem nach dem flugzeug einsturz in den usa zweitausendeins.
Kann man zwei geteilter meinung sein das muss natürlich vorher ankündigen führt natürlich dazu dass vor der ankündigung natürlich die leute dann massiv ihre aktien verkaufen würden.
Es ist die frage ob sich danach dann wieder in dementsprechend erholt oder in welche richtung sich danach entwickelt ich bin auch eher auf der seite zu sagen,
man sollte den markt einfach machen lassen in der form und jetzt nicht noch versuchen da in dieser form einzugreifen ich meine das was die leute verunsichert und das ist ja genau der punkt was du gerade sagst ist es,
das ist ein riesengroßer staub der gerade aufgewirbelt wird und niemand niemand oder die menschen hassen es nicht zu wissen was morgen passiert und das ist natürlich bei denen die in aktien anlegen genau das gleiche niemand weiß wie groß dieser schaden ist,
jegliche quartalszahlen die jetzt kommen kannst du ja können wir auch würfel ne aber du weißt nicht was da rauskommt und das verunsichert die leute.
Ich bin bei dir wenn sich dieser nebel liegt dann wird es auch alles wieder in irgendeiner form seinen normalen weg gehen und richtig wie du sagst in der zwischenzeit müssen wir gucken.
Dass wir all das was wir vorhatten am leben erhalten wie du gerade sagst der gastronom dem also hier in frankfurt selbst gut gehende restaurants geht innerhalb nach einem monat entsprechendes geld aus.
Da ist nichts mehr sondern die hilfspakete die jetzt natürlich alle geschnürt wurden diese meines erachtens gut,
sind durch dramatisch hoch wenn man das zumindest auch noch mal ins verhältnis setzt zu der finanzkrise zweitausendacht
also ich hab's mal angeschaut hier in in deutschland sind es ja bis zu je nachdem was natürlich dann zuerst greift bis zu über eine billion wenn man das noch mal ins verhältnis setzt zu der wirtschaftskraft also dem bruttoinlandsprodukt von deutschland und es ist ungefähr knapp dreißig prozent wenn alles denn zum zum zuge kommt,
darunter sind diese neue rekordversuch von den hundertsechsundfünfzig milliarden denn der rettungs-und für für kleinunternehmer,
wo man ja dann per heute entsprechend geld beantragen kann je nachdem wie viel mitarbeiter man hat plus natürlich diese garantie rahmen des bundes für für die kfz was ja auch nochmal um hundertfünfzig milliarden aufgestockt werden kann.
Also du fit bist sozusagen soweit gehst du mit bei dem beschlossenen maßnahmen.
Da gehe ich definitiv mit ich glaube also sie müssen in der form kommen ansonsten kommt es kommt es zum erliegen.
Ich glaube da ist es so dass gerade ein riesengroßer kater im boden ist und das gilt es erstmal diesen krater erstmal wieder zuzuschütten und erstmal irgendwie alles zu beruhigen danach.
Wenn sich die der staub gelegt hat dann müssen sich alle an einem tisch setzen und dann müssen wir doch mal anfangen zu diskutieren diese schulden jetzt leider aufgehäuft werden,
was passiert mit denen wer trägt diese schulden und was hat das nämlich für auswirkungen also die auswirkungen daraus resultierend die sind natürlich noch nicht so richtig klar also ich kann alles am laufen halten die leute haben wieder geld im portemonnaie aber was natürlich dann im hintergrund passiert das ist natürlich noch nicht ganz so klar was noch an den an den diskussionen.
Ich habe gestern mit jörg cookies telefoniert ist der staatssekretär im ministerium für für wirtschaft und finanzen.
Der sagt dass es tatsächlich auf der eu-ebene relativ wenig diskussionen gibt das ist relativ ungewöhnlich also die alle ziehen tatsächlich an einem strang das ist das eine.
Was nicht so erfreulich ist ist und das erlebt man natürlich jetzt auch auf der seite dadurch natürlich jetzt auf der kfw seite und auf den banken allem homeoffice sind,
funktioniert durch die kredit prüfung nicht einwandfrei also einfach auf der technischen ebene,
ich hoffe dass natürlich das geld was ich da ausgezahlt werden soll für manche leute eben halt nicht zu spät kommt es zu meine einzige befürchtung ich habe.
Wir müssen aufpassen dass wir uns mit den begriffen hier nicht verrennen also kaffee ist die kreditanstalt für wiederaufbau und das ist sozusagen die.
Nationale bank für.
Förderung weiß nicht wo wo die überall reingreift aber es ist halt eine anstalt des öffentlichen rechts und damit ein instrument des staates um gelder in die wirtschaft zu spüren da wo es erforderlich ist.
Also das was jetzt da im hintergrund passiert ist wenn ich im unternehmen bin und ab unter umständen wahrscheinlich kredit am laufen,
kann ich nun zu meiner hausbank gehen und sagen hat mal ich habe gerade kein geschäft ich muss über meine kreditkarten bedienen was können wir denn da machen entweder kannst du es stunden beziehungsweise du kannst einen neuen kredit aufnehmen.
Die banken sind natürlich darüber nicht gerade sehr happy weil sie sagen oh jetzt kommt natürlich jeder zu uns und möchte ihn kredit haben das risiko in der hausbank würde natürlich dann im entsteigen und da greifen die kaffee und sagt ok,
neunzig prozent der kredite die da jetzt vergeben werden versichern wir das heißt die hausbank hat in dem sinne kein risiko.
Oder zumindest nicht so ein hohes risiko.
Ich meine macht es schon sinn ich meine sammeln zwischen achtzig und neunzig prozent sind abgedeckte risiken auf der anderen seite muss die bank ihren kunden auch kennen also ich meine so ein bisschen müssen wir auch mit ins boot geholt werden und ein risiko eingehen ansonsten ja hätte die bank an ihren job im verfehlt.
Was wird denn auf europäischer seite gemacht oder was und was muss dort vor allem auch gemacht werden betrifft nicht nur deutschlands betrifft ja ganz europa alle nationalen wirtschaften sind davon jetzt betroffen,
welche rolle spielt da die zentralbank welche rolle spielt die kommission.
Das was wir jetzt gerade auf der kleinen ebene besprochen haben was einmal die besicherung von krediten der kfw für diese kleinen banken das kann man sich im grunde um so vorstellen passiert auch auf großer ebene.
Also die ezb hat natürlich riesengroße pakete nun beschlossen dass sie einerseits jetzt nochmal für umgerechnet knapp hundertzwanzig milliarden pro monat bis ende des jahres staatsanleihen kauft.
Was sind staatsanleihen also wenn ich ein land bin wie deutschland da muss ich ja auch gewisse dinge in diesem land finanzieren,
das heißt ich gebe eine anleihe raus und eine anleihe ist nichts anderes wie ein kredit der über einen gewissen zeitraum läuft sag mal zehn jahre und für diese anleihe.
Zahle ich auch einen zins an denjenigen der sie kauft und ganz zum schluss sage ich das geld entsprechend zurück.
Das passiert natürlich auch auf der ebene wie sag mal wie italien das problem an vitalen ist dass natürlich im vergleich zu deutschland die massiv überschuldet sind also grade italien griechenland spanien das was wir alles aus der finanzkrise kennen.
Was wir erlebt haben im zuge der krise und das darf natürlich nicht passieren es ist einerseits dass wir keine liquidität mehr in diesem markt haben also niemand war mehr bereit diesen ländern geld zu geben was natürlich tödlich ist.
Muss sich das so vorstellen dass im anleihenmarkt das ein bisschen anders funktioniert im vergleich zum aktienmarkt also im aktienmarkt habe ich eine börse tim sag ich möchte aktie für hundert kaufen ich sage ich möchte ich nicht ich biete dir nur neunundneunzig und irgendwo findet sich dann der preis.
Im anleihenmarkt funktioniert das so ein bisschen anders da gibt's eine art zwischenhändler also es gibt nicht direkt eine börse in dem sinne und dieser zwischenhändler der sitzt der market maker du sitzt irgendwo in einer bank und er hat ein gewisses buch.
Jetzt rufe ich dort an und sage ich möchte meine anleihe verkaufen und sagte ja nämlich ja für den und den preis.
Nur der dadurch von seiner bank ein gewisses risiko budget bereitgestellt wenn aber jetzt jeder massiv verkaufen will sagt er natürlich irgendwann mal.
Du weißt du was hier mein risiko buch ist voll da kann ich jetzt nichts mehr machen sondern kommen natürlich dieser markt ist dann stillstand da passiert halt nichts mehr und genau um das zu vermeiden tritt natürlich die ezb jetzt dort auf und sagt ich kaufe für,
mehrere milliarden pro monat entsprechend staatsanleihen was da mehrere effekte hat einerseits ich bringe vertrauen zurück in den markt weil sie jemand da der es hat kauft und auf der anderen seite ist es so dass,
die zinsen die ich für eine anleihe als als land an dem ausgeben müsst also wenn du jetzt eine kaufen möchtest steigt natürlich immens wenn die leute glauben wo italien ist irgendwie verschuldet,
und hoch verschuldet und die wirtschaft ist jetzt da am erliegen gekommen wenn du jetzt nochmal geld haben wollen dann zahle ich nicht ein prozent zinsen und da möchte ich halt irgendwie drei vier prozent haben weil es ja wesentlich risikoreicherer.
Was natürlich italien nicht hilft weil wir haben ja schon kein geld wie sollen sie dann noch das die die hohen zinsen bedienen und dadurch kommt die ezb wieder ins spiel und sagt hier liebes italien ich kaufe dir deine anleihen ab dann braucht es halt eben nicht so hohe zinsen zahlen.
Das hilft natürlich auf der anderen seite ja das geld muss ich irgendwo herkommen.
Und die die ezb druckt das geld dann einfach ne also wenn die ezb schlimmstenfalls wenn die staatsanleihen kauft dann weiß weiß jeder die kann es am ende bezahlen weil sie es im im endeffekt einfach drucken würde.
Ja genau also das ist gerade die aktuelle diskussion also.
Die sich diese schulden die bin ich jetzt italien diese anleihe abkaufen außer deren schulden irgendwann mal kommt der zeitpunkt nach zehn jahren wo italien natürlich die schulden begleichen muss dann ist natürlich alles fein,
gibt es natürlich diskussion zu sagen was passiert eigentlich auf der seite wenn wir die schulden einfach alle streichen würden weil die die die bilanz der ezb wird ja auch immer länger,
und per se kann aber eine eine eine eine fett oder eine nicht pleite gehen also das eigenkapital wird zwar dann gemindert einer bank wenn sie die anleihen die wir einfach rausstreichen aber sie kann auch nicht pleite gehen,
weil sie natürlich wie du gerade sagst per se immer neues geld quasi erschaffen kann.
Wo kommt denn das geld denn eigentlich her jetzt ich meine wenn jetzt gesagt wird wir stecken jetzt weiß nicht bundesrepublik deutschland hat jetzt irgendwas in der größenordnung von was war das hundertzwanzig milliarden habe ich das jetzt richtig in erinnerung
dieses rettungspaket gemacht also sozusagen dafür schulden aufgenommen ja wer,
gibt denn dieses geld ist das dann die ezb oder sind das andere länder ich meine die haben ja auch alle gerade keine kohle.
Andy also es gibt ja das bruttoinlandsprodukt wo wir gerade darüber gesprochen haben das ist also,
ja das was deutschland an wert schafft pro jahr durch dienstleistung service und so weiter,
und in im verhältnis dazu verschuldet sich ein land aktuell steht deutschland ungefähr bei bei sechzig prozent verhältnis italien nicht irgendwo bei hundertdreißig prozent,
deutschland sagt jetzt wir verschulden uns neu was ja auch politisch vorher no-go war da hieß es wir müssen an dieser schwarze null festhalten und per se jetzt in einer woche konnte man all das irgendwie einstimmig komplett auflösen,
wie so vieles und sie verschulden sich jetzt mit hundertsechsundfünfzig milliarden neu und diese verschuldung funktioniert genauso über online wie wir es gerade besprochen haben also deutschland wird es nämlich sagen hier wir brauchen geld hier ist eine neue anleihe per se deutschland ja.
Neben samuel norwegen schweden und so weiter eine der sichersten staaten in in der eu also werden die zinsen auch nicht allzu hoch sein und werde natürlich das geld entsprechend einsammeln bei leuten wie fondsmanagern pensionskassen und so weiter.
Und hinzu kommt das stimmt natürlich auch anleihen auch dann kaufen.
Würdest du dann mit deinem vor sowas auch kaufen.
Beim besten willen nicht weil es ökonomischer selbstmord ist.
Doch nicht so sicher.
Doch sicher ist es schon.
Wir haben ja also das ziel oder ist es ja zwei prozent inflation zu haben also inflation in form von preisanstieg,
die verzinsung auf diesem auf dieser bundesanleihe ist aber unter zwei prozent liegt dann aktuell irgendwie so teilweise im negativen bereich also ich soll jemandem geld leihen,
bekommen aber kaum zinsen dafür während gleichzeitig aber die preise um zwei prozent steigen also das heißt mein geld wird per se weniger wert also es macht ergonomisch gar keinen sinn.
Ja aber für wen machst du das denn überhaupt sinn dieses geld zu geben wo kommt denn dann her wer hat wer hat denn überhaupt das geld wird das erfunden oder ist das kommt es tatsächlich von irgendjemandem.
Ich sage ja nur dass es ökonomische selbstmord ist es gibt genug leute da draußen die er die sicherheit haben wollen und das geld dort einfach parken weil sie nicht wissen wo sonst hin mit dem geld ja genau.
Weil sie so viel davon haben wer ist denn wer ist denn das wer hat denn so viel wert und so viel geld dass sogar die zinsen egal sind dass man lieber geld verliert als als dass man's behält wer.
Familienkasse kirchen all diese leute die es dort gibt.
All die leute,
als ich meine auf der einen seite schreien auf der einen seite schreien alle wir haben kein geld gib uns geld und dann sagt man ja dann holen wir mal hundertsechsundfünfzig milliarden so aus dem nichts und dann frage ich mich wer sitzt denn auf diesem geld also,
die kirche ist das dein ernst.
Ich nehme bisschen auch ein bundesanleihen klar das ist ja das ist ja der punkt also wenn du das mal klarzustellen wir haben als asset-klasse irgendwie aktien wie wir gerade sehen schwanken die in den kursen sehr stark mögen die leute nicht,
bietet aber eine hohe rendite dann in ganz berlin werden immobilien alle weg gekauft und die leute freuen sich halt alle und denkt oh ich habe was stabiles gekauft.
Immer die renditen auf seiner immobilie liegen in berlin mittlerweile wo bei zwei prozent je nachdem wo man was bekommt teilweise drei prozent je nachdem.
Das schwankt natürlich nicht im preis weil nämlich keine börse da ist die jeden tag den preis dann immobilie anzeigt und wie der name schon sagt ist auch gleichzeitig noch nicht mobil also also kannst du nicht von heute auf morgen deine immobilie halt verkaufen,
aber das empfinden die leute als sicherheit also das was die leute am meisten angst vor haben ist von dieser schwankung,
so geht's natürlich auch solchen institutionen wir müssen nicht nur kirchen nehmen es gibt irgendwie familienstiftung et cetera die genau auch dafür hat irgendwie angst haben,
und ihr ihr portfolio was sie haben können sie nicht zu hundert prozent und aktien investieren weil sie entsprechend das risiko einer eines eines gesamt portfolios gemessen wird anhand ihrer schwankungsbreite.
Aber ist das jetzt so dass wir in deutschland sagt wir brauchen mal hundertsechsundfünfzig milliarden euro dass die sich auch sofort finden.
Hundertprozentig passiert wahrscheinlich gibt es mehr nachfrage als als die hundertsechsundfünfzig milliarden.
Woher kommt dieses geld kommt das aus deutschland ja aber die anderen länder haben da jetzt alle auch dasselbe problem.
Also wer ist das sind das irgendwelche russischen besitzer oder sind das irgendwie million milliardäre billiard äre also sind das einzelne person die einfach mega reich sind sind es einfach was für für kongo gerate greifen denn dazu.
Wenn du musst es ja wie breit sehen also du hast ja unterschiedliche leute du kannst unternehmen haben was wir schon hatten pensionskassen die riesengroße gelder verwalten im einfach nur pensionskasse die für dich vielleicht eine dein rentenanspruch irgendwann mal bedienen müssen.
Sie können ja gar nicht nur in aktien investieren also das ist jetzt zum beispiel auch so ein punkt die ganzen babyboomer in den usa die jetzt mal kurz vor der rente stehen in aktien investiert haben gerade in usa damit sie ein riesengroßes problem weil von jetzt auf gleich ist dreißig prozent ihres vermögens vernichtet worden und genau.
Solche pensionskassen die sehen wie gibt wenn du da dein geld investierst die müssen ja gucken dass eben das genau nicht passiert und die haben nur die alternative dass sie ihnen diese staatsanleihen investieren können.
Hilft dir das hoffentlich.
Ja das hilft mir ich meine das hier ist nicht nicht so dass man jetzt täglich mit solchen mengen an geld irgendwie im kopf jongliert oder sich klar macht,
wieviel geld überhaupt da ist ja und weil letzten endes klingt das für mich so das ganze geld liegt in deutschland sowieso irgendwie rum.
Hallo.
Und bisher hat noch keiner danach gefragt wenn man halt mal was braucht dann ist auch gleich da.
Auch eine interessante erkenntnis.
Ich habe mal ausgerechnet also ich meine nummer die nummer als gedankenspiel wenn das ganze geld jetzt nicht ausreicht.
Wenn man allen steuern zahlen in der gesamten eu dreitausend euro zukommen lassen würde so als helikopter geld es gibt ungefähr zweihundert millionen steuerzahler,
in der eurozone so mal dreitausend euro es werden sechshundert milliarden daraus macht man irgendwie so eine anleihe was wir gerade darüber gesprochen haben lässt die fünfzig jahre laufen eurobonds oder corona bond,
ich glaube es wird auch funktionieren und hätte jeder in der eu dreitausend euro portemonnaie also das kann ich mir als lösung vorstellen wenn das jetzt alles nicht hilft.
Ah
Ein problem haben wir nicht das ist das geldproblem nur leider hilft es halt nicht.
Dann erklären wir dann nochmal ganz kurz es gab ja schon in der griechenlandkrise diesen streit auf europäischer ebene mit diesen eurobonds.
Ob man die denn jetzt aufsetzt oder nicht was was wäre das gewesen warum sollte man das nicht und ist das jetzt wieder zu in der diskussion.
Ja genau also das ist ja dieses dieses phänomen dass wir in in also ich glaube dass die amerikaner.
Ihr problem ist wirtschaftliches problem relativ gut alleine lösen können und relativ gut aus der krise wieder rauskommen denn zum einen sind sie nicht export abhängig also sprich ihre produkte werden nicht komplett irgendwo ins ausland verkauft sondern sie leben halt davon dass die amerikanischen bürger.
Die produkte kaufen von amerikanischen unternehmen also das geld wird im inland generiert was bei uns eben nicht der fall ist warum tun wir uns natürlich in deutschland gerade so schwer.
Das heißt wir haben eigentlich drei probleme die wir irgendwie lösen müssen wir müssen irgendwie die schuldenkrise also die unternehmen zunächst mal jetzt unterstützen in der in der in der aktuellen krise wir müssen eine schuldenkrise danach abwenden und wir müssen die finanzmärkte irgendwie beruhigen,
die schuldenkrise abzuwenden bedeutet natürlich dass wir irgendwo als als europäische vereinigung natürlich zusammenhalten müssen was man sich gerade jetzt sieht was ungefähr null funktioniert.
Und dazu zählt auch dass man lange zeit überlegt hat eurobonds auszugeben das heißt sie sind also ich dachte gerade italien zum beispiel ist hochverschuldet neben spanien neben griechenland,
während es deutschland und oben die nordex die entsprechend natürlich gut geht.
Was natürlich passieren würde wenn man eurobonds ausgeben würde also für die gesamte europäische vereinigung dann würden ja die schulden von den ländern von italien quasi.
Unter einem hut gepackt also das heißt er würde jemand sagen eine nordics wieso ich habe doch gut gewirtschaftet was soll ich mich denn jetzt um die schulden von jemandem kümmern der sein geld zum fenster rausgeworfen hat sich nicht um gekümmert hat.
Es ist so wenn du in einer wg lebst ich spüle immer den ganzen tag ab ja mach immer mal in meinem job ganz gut wenn ich dienst habe und der tim hat irgendwie dienst aber der spielt halt irgendwie nie dann sage ich auch immer mal hier was soll ich jetzt für den tim den spülen ich habe meine meine sache erledigt aber warum soll ich das für ein tipp noch spüren.
Www wie wie bayern und baden-württemberg im länderfinanzausgleich ne.
Exakt und das nur im großen und die diskussion kommen natürlich jetzt erneut auf weil das wäre natürlich eigentlich die lösung zu sagen als eu halten wir zusammen und somit wir natürlich die komplette finanzierung auch über europa.
Das heißt wenn ich das richtig verstehe würdest du das an sich als instrument,
so als europäischer move durchaus als angemessen ansehen weil es ja sozusagen den druck auf die schwachen macht es würde aber eben nur bedeuten dass wir quasi ein bisschen von unserem reichtum teilen müssten das wäre doch am ende sowieso müssen.
Ja also ich meine dieser punkt den müssen wir auf jeden fall diskutieren wenn wenn wenn es sich jetzt mal alles erledigt hat also ich meine.
Entschuldigung wir sind wir sind in der europäischen union frankreich hat gesagt alle schutzkleidung alle handschuhe die werden jetzt immer verstaatlicht die dürfen nicht mehr rausgegeben werden tag später sagt deutschland ab jetzt export verbot auch von handschuhe und so weiter in jegliches europäisches land ich meine.
Wir leben doch hier alle zusammen in einer vereinigung wie kann ich denn sagen ich exekutiere keine handschuhe mehr mittlerweile hat nämlich auch deutschland ein bisschen zurückgerudert.
Also ich glaube wir kommen nicht drum herum dieses problem irgendwann mal langfristig zu lösen wenn wir nicht wollen dass die komplette eu in als das konzept wie es gerade existiert nicht irgendwann mal zusammenbricht und jeder wieder für sich alleine wurschtelt.
Was ich sehr bedauerlich finden würde weil es für jeden nur nachteile bringen würde.
Vielleicht so zum abschluss jetzt erleben wir ja eine ganz interessante
also interessant in anführungsstrichen das soll jetzt gleich mal vorweg zuschieben mich,
will jetzt hier nicht mit mit häme auf irgendwelche bereiche zeigen mit ihr habt aber jetzt mal echt pech gehabt sondern einfach nur mal so trocken drauf schauen was sozusagen jetzt die bereiche sind die,
einerseits sehr leiden müssen da hat man jetzt ein paar beispiele ja auch schon da manche die
vielleicht gerade leiden aber die potenziell dass wenn irgendwann die wirtschaft wieder läuft das mittelfristig auch wieder reinbekommen ja dann gibt's natürlich auch totale
krisen gewinner die gibt es ja immer irgendwie irgendwas ist halt immer gerade in der nachfrage ja lieferdienste würden wir jetzt als erstes so einfallen wie wie siehst du das und was,
deutet das eigentlich für das wirtschaftliche system dass wir in so einer ganz kurzen zeit solche disruptiven elemente haben,
also kann das zum beispiel auch belebender positiver faktor sein.
Ja das glaube ich schon in der vergangenheit war es immer so gewesen dass,
der krisen tatsächlich auch in art disruptiv wie du gerade selber sagst wie ein disruptiven element in in sich tragen.
Sowohl negativ als auch positiv nehmen wir dem elften september,
was natürlich dazu geführt hat dass wir an verstärkten einsatz von von von digitalen überwachungstechnologien haben ich glaube daher ist natürlich der ursprung müssen wir durch im negativen bereich angekommen oder je nachdem wie man da fragt quasi.
Und das gleiche wird in dieser form auch passieren also weil was sieht man die leute stellen fest,
ich muss ja gar nicht mehr um den halben planeten reisen um irgendwelche leute zu treffen ich kann ja auch irgendwie so um skype oder facetime halt irgendwo nehmen also ich glaube dass das vielleicht eine form sein kann zu sagen wir haben effekte,
das gewisse businessmeetings tatsächlich im büro stattfinden und wir so nebeneffekt haben das was man wegen die die umwelt dadurch noch parallel irgendwo sich etwas erholt ich glaube,
das was greta und co fordern wird es glaube ich gerade mehr erfüllt als sie sich selbst wahrscheinlich gerade erträumen lassen natürlich zu lasten von vielen anderen dingen.
Also halten wir mal ein guter punkt ne können wir mal festhalten plus companys alles speziell was jetzt im video konferenzbereich zu tun hat cisco etcetera diese ganze netzwerk infrastruktur,
digitale hier gewinnt es glaube ich vollkommen klar aber heißt dann weniger flugreisen weniger hotelaufenthalt e weniger konferenz buchung et cetera das heißt das könnte auch schon sein dass es da irgendwie eine langfristige.
Abwärtsbewegung sieht oder zumindest keine verstärkung.
Dann auf der gesellschaftlichen ebene ist der punkt viele sagen natürlich also diese also was will ich jetzt alle feststellen dass diese welt ist ziemlich fragil wir haben uns immer darauf verlassen globalisierung und digitalisierung funktioniert wunderbar ich gehe im supermarkt ich finde alles jetzt gehe ich hin und ja ist halt nicht immer alles da.
Das ist natürlich viele leute überraschend und darauf hat man sich sehr lange darauf verlassen und offensichtlich gibt es keinen plan b,
das merkt man natürlich jetzt auch dass irgendwie lieferketten umgerüstet werden müssen,
klopapier selber ist natürlich genug da ist natürlich zum teil auch einfach nur ein logistisches problem dieses klopapier nicht mein hotels liefern ich muss jetzt irgendwie umleiten dass es ihm im im rossmann dm halt irgendwie ankommt ja also das ist so das logistisches problem,
justin time produktion und jetzt muss ich mir lieferketten ändern das aber im digitales problem in dem sinne was man aber auch wie lösen kann.
Aber jetzt fordern die leute und sagen wir müssen weg von dieser globalisierung das sehe ich zum beispiel nicht so weil.
Was halt null sinn macht ich glaube wir ziehen als gesellschaft die stärke aus dieser globalisierung und bei subway,
ob wir's globalisiert wären oder nicht selbst wenn wir uns wenn jeder staat für sich selber sein eigenes ding machen würde würde der virus ja trotzdem zu uns kommen.
Dann würde man jetzt sagen dann dürfte ich keine flugzeug keine bahn mehr haben aber selbst wenn wir nochmal in dem zeitstrahl rückwärts geben zu zeiten wo es ein esel und pferd gab auch selbst da hat sich ein virus verbreitet tatsächlich muss man den zeitstrahl so weit zurückgehen dass wir in der steinzeit ankommen,
da hat man in so kleinen kommunen gelebt hat sich so ein virus nicht verbreitet also wenn wir die steinzeit zurück wollen ja dann haben wir auch kein virus mehr also den gibt's schon noch aber verbreitet sich nämlich.
Naja und vor allem weil es gibt natürlich schon so aspekt
wie zum beispiel was weiß ich jetzt hier medikamentenversorgung jetzt stellt man auf einmal fest dass alle wichtigen grundstoffe wesentlich nur noch aus china und indien kommen und wenn die sagen auch das brauchen wir jetzt aber mal für uns so dann steht man halt blöd
da also man muss schon sozusagen eine gewisse resilienz
pool aufbauen dass man sozusagen in krisenzeiten sowas auch noch machen kann genauso natürlich grundversorgung krankenhäuser ist das natürlich die dinge die jetzt gerade ganz offensichtlich sind
aber auch in den wirtschaftlichen gebahnt muss mal schauen so
ist so single sourcing überhaupt eine gute idee oder sind sozusagen die lieferketten auch ausreichend krisenfest so dass man eben auch immer,
in der lage ist umschalten zu können.
Das ist das was ich heute mit plan b meint hast du absolut recht genau sich auch so und zumal wenn ich's jeder versucht selbstversorger zu werden will er gar nicht funktionieren da wird natürlich in vielen ländern die menschen verhungern also das das macht gar keinen sinn.
Genau ist ja nicht so dass man in jedem land alles bekommen könnte was man heute meint zu brauchen.
Was man gerade erlebt in meinem unternehmen denen ich spreche auf der forschung seite es ist tatsächlich so dass was sonst in einem jahr oder mehrere jahre gedauert hätte funktioniert tatsächlich jetzt in mehreren monaten einfach weil.
Mal komplett gewinne oder ein ego oder was auch immer außen vor gelassen wird und wirklich halt unternehmen zusammenarbeiten und sagen wir müssen jetzt versuchen hierfür einen impfstoff zu zu bekommen,
also es scheint ja irgendwie vieles auch schneller machbar zu sein dem einfach mal gewisse grenzen einfach überwindet und ich glaube das kann auch ein vorteil sein ich meine.
Wer ist denn nicht sinnvoller gewesen wenn wir auch einfach zum beispiel informationen geteilt hätten also wenn wir viel früher die information aus wenn sie denn hoffentlich nicht gelogen werden aus china und korea et cetera bekommen hätten oder aus taiwan und hätten die
wir haben in einem netzwerk die informationen zusammen verarbeitet ich glaube wenn wir auch viel schneller aus dieser krise gekommen vielleicht können wir zu dem punkt zu sagen wir müssen mehr informationsaustausch auf dieser welt haben.
Ich glaube die information waren aber auch teilweise da wollten aber einfach auch nicht gehört werden.
Ja ich meine das auch auf software ja gut vielleicht ja stimmt.
Die
dann auch die entsprechenden politischen schritte zu machen war halt nicht da ich meine wir haben ja selber sehr gut gesehen und es ist eine interessante lehre wie schwer man sich auch individuell mit dem gedanken,
tat das jetzt so einen look down auch wirklich erforderlich ist weil dann betrifft dich das in irgendetwas und du musst dann erstmal deine ganzen prioritäten,
umschalten so und wenn's nur fußball ist wo die leute dann so wie was,
kein fußball ja geht denn die welt jetzt unter oder was so so ja genau das passiert jetzt übrigens gerade und dass das mit dem weltuntergang muss man halt auch erstmal checken so und das ist natürlich auch.
Bis das in jedem selbst hinein gerieselt ist ich glaube da haben wir alle irgendwie eine woche gebraucht manche mögen's schon früher gefühlt haben andere waren sich nicht so sicher,
ganz viele andere denken sich vielleicht auch jetzt noch habt ihr sie denn noch alle aber auch das wird sich sicherlich ein bisschen geändert haben und in dem moment wo irgendwas wieder besser läuft wird natürlich auch wieder viel von dem verloren gegangen sein aber ich glaube,
auch was du sagst dass man diese diese dieses in dem moment wo man die fragilität spürt,
so dann kann man zumindest für eine bestimmte zeit auch erstmal sagen okay alles klar wir sollten uns mehr auf unsere eigene resilienz konzentrieren und nicht auch alles als selbstverständlich ansehen.
Das heißt du hast das mit dem fußball jetzt überwunden tim.
Ich habe mich habe mein mein frieden so ein bisschen damit gefunden es war aber nicht einfach das kann ich dir wirklich sagen zumal da ja auch noch ganz andere dramen sich
abzeichnet aber ich stelle das dann auch irgendwann mal zurück hinter das allgemeine wohl so so so generell ist bin ich.
Das immer wieder erstaunlich.
Bitte so ein tausendsassa in der hinsicht irre.
Was ich mir vorstellen kann ist dass wir nach grunde einfach eine neue weltordnung sehen könnten in form von also weg von isolation und weniger vertrauen hin zu mehr solidarität und mehr vertrauen.
Das ist ein schöner optimistischer blick ich meine jetzt haben wir den siebenundzwanzigsten märz und ist ja mit den zukunfts aussagen immer so eine sache aber ehrlich gesagt ich habe kein besonders gutes gefühl was so den zustand der usa in der nächsten woche betrifft,
weil ich einfach also ich rechne zumindest damit ich weiß nicht ob es passieren wird also es würde mich jetzt schon fast überraschen wenn es nicht so kommt aber ich rechne da eigentlich mit dem schlimmsten ich denke dass sie das nicht unter kontrolle bekommen werden und das.
All die ganzen netze die sie nicht aufgespannt haben sozusagen nichts mehr verhindern können.
Weil einfach ihre.
Ihre wirtschaft schlecht abgesichert ist ne drei millionen leute entlassen innerhalb von ein paar tagen das spricht schon für sich was ja da in den usa auch bedeutet dass die leute keinen,
krankenversicherung schutz mehr haben was gerade in der aktuellen.
Den hatten die vorher auch nicht.
Na ja zumindest hattest du in bestimmten betrieben gebunden an deinen job so etwas und in dem moment wo du dann gefeuert wirst hast du das halt dann gar nicht mehr und das war so so von einem tag auf den anderen,
und in einer situation wo es dann geraten ist dass leute sich dann auch mal testen lassen sollten,
mit dem gedanken so oh gott das kostet mich jetzt dreitausend dollar,
wenn ihr das dann halt nicht tun und brauchen aber auch auf einmal kohle nehmen jeden job an
bleibt nicht zuhause weil sie nichts zu fressen haben weil sie keine lohnvorzahlung bekommen und so weiter also das ist ja eine eine ganze kette
von umständen die in dieser aktuellen situation wirklich bitter ist und ich kann nur hoffen dass sie halt in irgendeiner form dann noch die kurve bekommen aber dafür haben sie einfach derzeit nicht
die richtige politische lage weil eben diese spaltung der gesellschaft die sie da wirklich schon perfektioniert haben da einfach,
gegen arbeitet und ähnlich sehe es halt in etwas abgemeldetes form im vereinigten königreich wo sie sich im prinzip dasselbe in grün übergezogen haben und jetzt halt schön doof dastehen.
Ja also das sehe ich ja ganz anders die reaktion von donald trump war großartig also ganz ganz toll die sind jetzt auch endlich führend bei korona also,
zumindest bei der anzahl der infizierten.
Am besten anders.
Und das obwohl sie so wenig testen ja also da ist jetzt endlich mal wieder america first.
Ja da kann man jetzt irgendwie natürlich sarkastisch sich das anschauen aber ich glaube so richtig zu unser aller wohl kann das nicht sein weil im allerschlimmsten fall kann halt die usa als markt komplett zusammenfallen,
und das ist nicht lustig wo soll ich denn dann nur ein neues iphone herkriegen.
Wo ich sagen muss dass diese des hilfspaket ist ja zunächst mal im senat das erste mal gescheitert weil die demokratinnen und einwände hatten und die waren aber relativ gut gewesen,
trump wollte ich einfach nur geld geben und das war's ohne irgendwelche bedingungen geknüpft und die demokraten haben wir uns ja nochmal durchgerungen zu sagen wenn ein unternehmen geld bekommt,
dann darf es die nächsten fünf jahre die mitarbeiter nicht entlassen und die die scheinen lassen wurden müssen wieder eingestellt werden schon mal ein positives zeichen,
und es gilt nur für leute unter einem jahreseinkommen von fünfundzwanzigtausend euro.
Trump hatte einfach das gemacht ohne diese rahmenbedingungen wobei ich genau diese rahmenbedingung gut finde weil es nämlich den leuten einfach vertrauen gibt zu wissen ich kriege jetzt geld per check,
und ich habe aber morgen auch noch einen job weil dann gebe ich das geld nämlich auch aus und behalten nicht mal ein portemonnaie schon hatten.
Du hast gerade so ein aspekt angesprochen,
dass es also vielleicht insgesamt in eine solidarische ihre welt gehen könnte oder so ne das ist ja
also viele völlig völlig völlig illusionen näherte hippies stellt sich das ja die ganze zeit vor.
Einige blüten haben wir aber genau in dieser richtung die ich auch ganz interessant finde zum.
Beispiel in berlin gibt es jetzt unterschiedliche möglichkeiten oder ideen das,
komm jetzt nochmal auf diese gastronomie zurück aber das ich glaube das sind auch angebote die für den einzelhandel ähnlich gelten würden.
Wo man jetzt quasi gutscheine kaufen kann ja das heißt du kaufst jetzt irgendwie ein gutschein für eine von der schließung betroffen das geschäft das kann,
ein haarschneider salon denke ich genauso sein wie eine gastronomie städte wie,
ist er das ökonomisch zu bewerten weil da habe ich mich natürlich auch im in den diskussionen darüber gestritten wie man das ökonomisch betrachtet ich würde sagen,
einen besseren kredit kannst du gar nicht bekommen weil wenn da jetzt jemanden also nehmen wir ein bier in der kneipe nimmt jetzt jemanden gibt jetzt zwei euro kauft ein bier gutschein.
Du musst ja eigentlich nur im supermarkt oder in der metro für achtzig cent ein bier kaufen und dem geben mit anderen worten ziemlich guter kredit.
Wenn du jetzt an die überbrückung
denkst ja es wäre würde ich sagen einfacher wieder zu erwirtschaften als mit dem gleichen geld für zwei euro achtzig cent bier verkauft haben am ende zwei euro zurückzahlen zu müssen,
eine andere perspektive darauf ist wenn wir jetzt wenn ich endlich den laden wieder aufmachen darf.
Und da stehen erstmal hunderte oder tausende kundinnen vor der tür die.
Im prinzip monatseinkommen oder komplette mietzahlungen in gutscheinen in der hand haben wir dann im nächsten monat ruinieren weil er die leute dann die die plätze besetzen wie würdest du das als,
aus ökonomischer sicht sehen solche.
Solche hilfen und solche solidaritätsbad eben jetzt auch der konsumentinnen die zuhause sitzen in der online ja,
reste saufen aus dem weinkeller und sagen komm wer hat der hat ich kaufe jetzt mal hier ein gutschein für für bessere zeiten wie was hältst du von solchen projekten.
Also kurzfristig hilft es natürlich den bar betreiber weil natürlich nach wie vor geld bekommt was ihm unter diesen jetzigen umständen weggebrochen ist das heißt,
bekommt den cashflow days monatlich bekommt und das bier was er dafür eigentlich ausgeben muss zahlt er nicht jetzt sondern er zahlt es erstmal irgendwie in drei monaten später wie du es gerade richtig sagt ist.
Jetzt habe ich natürlich in unter umständen logistisches problem wenn natürlich je nachdem wie viele gutscheine ich verkauft habe der komplette monat danach mein lokal blockiert ist dann habe ich natürlich das problem nur verschoben auf den monat wo ich dann diese ganzen gutschein leute sitzen habe.
Ökonomische frage wäre wäre nicht ein kredit unter umständen günstiger es hängt natürlich von den zinsen ab das heißt also ich nehme lieber einen kredit auf zahl dafür.
Ja einen gewissen zins.
Dann hab ich natürlich ab tag eins bin ich wieder aufmache frische neue gäste die mir bier bei mir kaufen und der zins männer natürlich für den monat oder mehrere monate unter umständen ein wenig meine gewinnmarge.
Hängt davon ab wie hoch die margen sondern ein bar ist.
Ja meine.
Also keine keine.
Realistisch linus realistisch ist es ja so die vorstellung dass dann sozusagen sofort alle wieder in die bar rennen.
Nur noch mit gutscheinen bezahlen,
wird so auch nicht passieren so ne erstmal werden wir gerade im gastronomischen gewerbe selbst wenn wieder was aufmacht wird die angst dahin zu gehen,
erstmal sehr groß sein.
Die leute müssen sich erst mal wieder aneinander gewöhnen wie ich soll jetzt neben jemandem sitzen und da ist kein anderthalb meter abstand dazwischen das ist ja wie,
der hustet ja vielleicht doch das ist ja wie früher ja also das wird sowieso sehr lange dauern bis dieses vertrauen der nähe wieder zurückkommt einerseits andererseits könnte man natürlich.
Auch sich wieder eine hose anziehen.
Und das in der bar also,
du kannst natürlich andererseits auch trickreich vorgehen und den gutschein sozusagen einen ersten geltung tag draufdrucken und den sozusagen mit der zeit langsam hoch zählen lassen dass du eben automatisch.
Nee das geht natürlich nicht.
Wieso geht das nicht natürlich geht das wenn du das als bedingungen drauf schreibst und es wird.
Zu dem zeitpunkt wo du den gutschein verkaufst kannst du ja nicht nachher danach nochmal die bedingungen verändern.
Nein,
dann nicht nachher du schreibst es direkt auf den gutschein drauf saß dieser den den kaufst du heute den darfst du aber frühestens ab ersten juni benutzen.
So und das zählt dann halt immer einen tag hoch je nachdem wie da da sozusagen deine belastbarkeit ist muss man jetzt nicht machen könnte man aber machen,
also wenn es sich sozusagen abzeichnet dass das wirklich ein problem wird weil auf einmal so viele leute was kaufen eine andererseits hast du natürlich recht du hast im prinzip das geld schon vorher,
du hast es mehr oder weniger brutto komplett gut
abgesehen von der umsatzsteuer die müsstest du natürlich dann trotzdem abführen aber auch das lässt sich ja derzeit rauszögern also von daher hättest du wirklich eine,
ganz interessante liquidität wenn es sich tatsächlich verkauft und du kannst ja auch vor allem relativ gut einschätzen was sozusagen vorhalten musst später wenn du schon weißt was du alles los wirst und dann werden natürlich viele leute diese gutscheine auch nicht einlösen.
Da gehe ich nämlich aufhören aus ne also ich ich habe da jetzt zwei angebote für berlin insbesondere gesehen das eine war.
Helfen punkt berlin und das andere ist irgendwie so ein konzept vom tagesspiegel und diese sagten aber
was auch voll geil du sagst den leuten sie kriegen noch zehn prozent obendrauf ne und da würde ich sagen da also diese diese zehn prozent bei diesem krisen profiteure ja den den würde ich jetzt nicht die will ich jetzt nicht mit zehn prozent mehr saufen.
Weil einfach so ganz rein vom charakter her hätte ich lieber die leute die sagen komm ich hole für den honig gutschein für meine kneipe damit die kneipe überhaupt noch da ist,
wenn wenn ich wieder vor die tür gehen darf oder möchte oder so ne während ich die leute die sagen ich habe aber hier zehn prozent rendite auf meinen kneipen invest,
die willst du ja eigentlich nicht da stehen haben.
Ich glaube jetzt so kommt ihr auch nochmal dass es viele kneipen in berlin und auch hier in frankfurt gibt die natürlich sag mal,
ja so die kneipe ums eck ist und nicht irgendwelche modernen hipster kneipen die irgendwie durchfinanziert sind von a bis z um irgendwelche investment sind ich glaube die gilt es ja gerade erst recht zu schützen weil man möchte ja seine,
seine spielunke sage ich mal irgendwie noch irgendwie beibehalten und ich glaube ja wer vielleicht einfach geld über hat vielleicht einfach mal so geld im hut schmeißen ohne jetzt gleich irgendwie was dafür zu verlangen.
Also ich denke sogar dass hier eine chance besteht weil und das ist vielleicht auch vielen sozusagen nicht bewusst ne in dem moment wo man natürlich eher stammpublikum orientiert ist dann hat man also zumindest eine community die kann man auch in irgendeiner form ansprechen also man hat jetzt nicht vielleicht von allen eine e-mail-adresse rumliegen aber
da muss man halt daran arbeiten dass man diese community in irgendeiner form erreicht und auch das geht heutzutage deutlich einfacher weil ja eigentlich fast jeder laden mindestens eine facebook-seite am start hat.
Und diese ganzen seelenlosen ketten dinger wo man vielleicht mal reingeht und geld lässt aber mit dem man irgendwie keine verbindung hat die haben's natürlich schwerer aber da würde ich sagen das sind dann halt auch sozusagen noch die sachen die man am wenigsten,
vermisst klar da hängt dann auch arbeitsplätze dran etcetera aber das sind dann auch alles lücken die an anderer stelle wieder gefüllt werden während natürlich der verlust einer kneipe die seit dreißig jahren da ist und wohne community dran hängt die leute natürlich
sehr viel mehr trifft also wenn jetzt sozusagen meine lieblingsbands verschwenden komplett und sind dann vollständig weg
das würde in meinem leben natürlich einen größeren schaden zuführen als wenn jetzt irgendwo einen weg donald's nicht mehr da ist oder ein vapiano restaurant zu machen muss so da da nehme ich jetzt,
komme ich auf alle anderen nicht so ein schaden.
Das dinge wenn deine lieblingskneipe schließt ist ja im zweifelsfall auch dass dann da als nächstes donald's oder ein vapiano ist ja weil.
Das ist genau das andere ding ja.
Piano nicht mehr.
Ja aber piano ist ja jetzt schon pleite.
Aber das ist ja das das positive der krise dass natürlich also solche geschäftsmodelle wien vapiano oder auch so maredo die auch jetzt pleite gegangen sind,
die auch schon kurz an der grenze waren pleite zu gehen dass sie nämlich jetzt viel schneller aus dem markt rausgespült werden also scheint auch um die arbeitsplätze klar aber die wir ihnen kurz davor pleite zu gehen das erledigt natürlich jetzt irgendwie diese krise natürlich umso schneller.
Vielleicht so zum abschluss weil ich denke wir haben,
an sich das hier ganz gut abgefedert aber das passt jetzt glaube ich auch nochmal so ganz gut dazu wie man eigentlich helfen kann insbesondere sozusagen von von staatsseite was ja jetzt auch an allen ecken und enden wieder hochkommt ist so ideen wie.
Grundeinkommen et cetera ich meine es ist jetzt nichts was,
kurzfristig in irgendeiner form kommt das wird jetzt vielleicht in die gesellschaftliche debatte wieder neu eingebracht werden und,
muss man abwarten wie sich das entwickelt aber es gibt ja jetzt sozusagen auch kurzfristige maßnahmen,
die schon als ideen länger auf dem tisch waren die die sich durchaus umsetzen ließen also jetzt haben wir sozusagen diesen fall mit direkte hilfen ja man kriegt geld,
was siehst du denn auch für andere möglichkeiten also es gibt ja zum beispiel diese idee dieser negativen einkommenssteuer das heißt wenn ich jetzt sozusagen verlust gemacht habe ja dann ist es ja bisher nur so dass ich irgendwie keine steuern zahle,
aber es ist halt nicht so dass ich für meinen verlust geld wieder zurückbekomme diese negative einkommenssteuer als idee.
Sind da irgendwelche konzepte im raum die dir sinnvoll erscheinen.
Mit den negativen stress ja nur der punkt dass ich nicht umgedreht dem den bürgern geld geben kann also die usa ist es relativ simpel kriegt tatsächlich in papierform check das würde hier in deutschland oder in der eu gar nicht funktionieren.
Ja doch papierform würde funktionieren ja wahrscheinlich weil irgendwie alle irgendwo gelistet sind beim bürgeramt hoffentlich,
aber ich kann jetzt nicht zum beispiel jeden auf seinem konto was überweisen weil tatsächlich diese daten nicht alle komplett miteinander verknüpft sind und ich kann es nur über diese steuergeschenke halt lösen ich glaube das ist der effekt einfach daraus also mit der negativen steuer genau.
Also da stimmt du mir sozusagen zu dass das dass das durchaus ein hebel wäre bei dem man nachdenken könnte.
Ja durchaus ich glaube der punkt ist wenn wenn jetzt einmal sich was wir gerade hatten wenn sich jetzt der nebel liegt und man sich an einen tisch setzt.
Dann komme ich sicherlich viele konzepte auf dem tisch dabei leute vergessen immer,
es muss ja irgendwo eine zentrale oder eine motivation von irgendetwas kommen also warum soll es irgendjemand sich komplett umstellen und,
politiker ist für vier jahre gewählt was hat er jetzt davon zu sagen wir müssen jetzt nicht so dass halt irgendwo ändern also ich meine ich glaube muss sich erst noch darüber überlegen woher kommt der motivationsschub bereit zu sein etwas zu verändern.
Ich glaube das ist nochmal so so eine übergeordnete ebene.
Also auch bedingungsloses grundeinkommen klar gibt es also wir werden irgendwann an unserer gesellschaft in den punkt kommen wo wir darüber nachdenken müssen.
Ich sage nicht des kapitalismus das beste ist aber es gibt auch bisher keine andere form die besser war also aber vielleicht kann man's modifizieren oder vielleicht gibt es ein anderes konzept das muss natürlich erstmal einfach mal langfristig halt diskutieren.
Woher soll der druck kommen dass jetzt damit zu tun ich hoffe zumindest dass jetzt die krise vielleicht dazu irgendwie ausreichend,
das sehen wir auch wenn ich mit japanischen firmen spreche jetzt gerade in der robotik sache zum beispiel dass ich das auch beschleunigt gut für vielleicht zu dem effekt dass wir irgendwie was ich fünf jahre eher alle keine jobs mehr haben dann kommen vielleicht tatsächlich doch immer mehr zu dieser diskussion.
Hallo.
Ich hätte ich hätte noch eine andere perspektive für die zukunft auf dem herzen was glaubst du denn.
Bei all diesen maßnahmen die wir jetzt besprochen haben wie lange sich der spaß überhaupt aufrecht erhalten lässt denn,
was hier ja eigentlich mit diesem flatternde körbe und sonstigen scherzen diskutiert wird sind ja perspektiven von,
vielen monaten und es ist nicht so wirklich erkenntlich.
Dass.
Dass das jetzt irgendwie ein schnelles ende finden wird ja mit dem problem korona die wir lernen im daily trosten,
dass es irgendwie so sobald sechzig siebzig prozent hier durch gesäugt sind dann durch säugt sind dann haben wir eine chance zu einer normalität zurückzukehren es gibt hoffnung dass,
vielleicht der durch solche grad schon höher ist weil es hoffentlich eine ganze reihe an leuten gibt die,
asymmetrie romantisch dadurch kommen dass es irgendwie wahrscheinlich die größte hoffnung die wir im moment haben wenn wir sagen würden jede person die.
Infiziert ist merkt das auch und wird im zweifelsfall auch getestet dann haben wir auf jeden fall noch einen langen weg vor uns ja also wenn wir sagen die infektionskrankheit die wir gerade gemessen haben
in deutschland was waren das jetzt dreißigtausend glaube ich aktuell oder wenn wir davon ausgehen die muss noch.
Einerseits mit einer flachen kurve aber die muss auf irgendwo fünfzig millionen kommen bei den dann haben wir auf jeden fall noch längere zeit.
Homeoffice vor uns.
Irgendwann wird der moment kommen und in den usa ist er ja jetzt schon laut geworden an anderen stellen kommen die stimmen auch jetzt schon langsam die sagen okay wir machen,
im prinzip haben wir mit jetzt sagen wir mal ein paar wochen social distance.
An verschiedenen stellen der erde oder noch nicht einmal social distanz zink festgestellt auch in berlin haben die ersten maßnahmen gerade mal vor zwei wochen angefangen hiermit kindergarten schließen und solchen scherzen.
Da wird schon so einen schaden mit angerichtet und solche katastrophalen milliarden milliarden pakete uns aufgeheizt dass wir,
de facto das nicht besonders lange weitermachen können bisher wirklich die weltwirtschaft vernichtet haben und dann wird ja der müsste doch,
werden die stimmen natürlich lauter werden die sagen okay.
Das können wir uns nicht leisten beziehungsweise irgendwann die stimmen kommen oder also irgendwann wird das nicht mehr zu kompensieren sein und dieses risiko scheint doch durchaus im raum zu stehen also wie würdest du das betrachten.
Im jahre zweitausendacht zu der damaligen finanzkrise hat man sich ungefähr zu achtzig prozent verschuldet
was ungefähr im gegenwert von knapp eine billion entspricht was jetzt auch wie jetzt auch gemacht haben grob plus minus das hat ungefähr gereicht für oder würde reichen für vier
knapp vier monate um alles so aufrechtzuhalten selbst wenn die wirtschaft bei null ist also für vier monate ungefähr haben wir auf der ebene sag ich mal luft.
Was müssen wir jetzt in diesen vier monaten hinbekommen wir werden impfstoff nicht vor ende des jahres bekommen also es gibt irgendwie so neunundsechzig kandidaten die gerade in werde getestet werden
dieses verfahren sind zwar alle beschleunigt aber das wird sicherlich bis ende des jahres dauern und selbst wenn wir dann im stoff haben dann haben wir noch das problem dass wir in den massen produzieren müssen und das wird noch mal der nächste knackpunkt sein.
Freunde des jahres ist damit nicht zu rechnen.
Was natürlich jetzt die jetzt sind wir zwei wochen in deutschland alle zuhause und die effekte daraus müssen wir jetzt hier in den nächsten wochen sehen weil zwei wochen dauert es ja bis ich nicht mehr den den virus übertrage also
die effekte in deutschland müssten wir eigentlich jetzt in den nächsten wochen sehen ob das was gebracht hat was wir gerade tun oder halt eben nicht.
Das was jetzt auf den markt gekommen ist und das sollte man vielleicht diskutieren es ist eine art schnelltest also moment dauert es ja wenn ich wenn ich überhaupt mein test machen darf und kann dann dauert dieser test irgendwie zwei tage und die kapazitäten in laboren ist irgendwie überlastet.
Es gibt es von von bosch schon auch von kia gehen und von vielen anderen firmen ein art schnelltest der im april verfügbar ist so sich ein ergebnis habe innerhalb von zwei stunden,
die überlegung könnte ja sein ich teste in riesengroßen mengen und die menschen die.
Also das schon hinter sich haben die kommunen sind die kann ich ja wieder nach draußen lassen anführungsstrichen und die können ja dann in der zeit langsam die die wirtschaft wieder hochfahren in dem maße wie es vielleicht vorher gewohnt waren oder zumindest ein teil davon,
um das halt in einer gewissen art und weise abzufedern das ist zumindest meine überlegung wie wir dahin kommen.
Aber das werden ja auch dann nur wenige tausend trümmerfrauen sein die dann anfangen dürfen die wirtschaft wieder aufzubauen in vier monaten.
Also ich meine an dem tag wo alle wieder rausgelassen werden und das von heute auf morgen wieder losgeht glaube ich schon dass wir so einen punkt erleben wo jetzt alle massiv in den restaurants gehen und die bars gehen dass sie dass die leute mehr kunden haben als jemand zuvor das wir könnte so einen positiven effekt sein was auch vieles wieder auffängt damit ich jetzt vergessen.
Ich sehe jetzt kein szenario also mir fällt es schwer zu sagen das wird jetzt noch ein jahr so dauern oder irgendwie sechs monate ich glaube schon dass es jetzt relativ zügig geht um zu sehen die maßnahmen deutschland helfen.
Ich glaube wir werden natürlich jetzt auch sehen dass wir viel mehr leute haben die natürlich jetzt daran sterben werden weil jetzt so langsam die intensivbetten gefüllt werden also die bilder werden nicht schön sein aber dann haben wir dieses tal der tränen so blöd wie es klingt aber eigentlich durchschritten.
Na ja gut ich meine das jetzt natürlich jetzt voraus dass der die bisherige annahme der dauer immunität auch so gegeben ist so da gibt's noch sehr,
unterschiedliche signale dass man sozusagen,
mit den tests auch die entsprechenden erfolge erzielt also wenn man heute von tests redet muss man auch mal,
grundsätzlich zwei tests unterscheiden nämlich diese tests auf hast du das mal gehabt und bist du gerade akut gefährdet ne also letzteres ist noch schwieriger zu skalieren aber diese immunität ist vorstellbar dass man,
in dem monat da wirklich auf nennenswerte zahlen kommen kann und dann werden wir überhaupt erst sehen wie es mit seiner ganzen legalität aussieht etcetera aber die unsicherheit wird natürlich noch eine ganze weile lang bleiben.
Und ich glaube so den tag wo gesagt wird so jetzt ist wieder alles supi und alle stürzen irgendwie in die biergärten
den werden wir so nicht erleben das wird so ein gradueller prozess sein und wieder genau ausfällt und vor allem ab wann der möglich ist das wird noch von allem abhängen sondern wir werden uns wahrscheinlich auch einige änderungen einstellen müssen auch langfristig
wie langfristig werden wir sehen,
da können wir jetzt hier rum orakel in diesem podcast oder nicht das wird daran in der realität relativ wenig erinnern aber ich denke man muss diese bereitschaft entwickeln man muss.
Für sich sollte jeder mal klar machen so okay dinge werden sich ändern und man muss auch,
und linus hat ja als wir das erste mal das thema aufgegriffen haben auch zu diesen bereich sind depressionen und wie fühle ich mich sozusagen damit aufgegriffen ne man muss sozusagen glaube ich auch an sich arbeiten dass man jetzt so eine so eine bereitschaft auch dafür entwickelt dass man sagt,
was auch kommt es kommt und wir werden das schon irgendwie eingearbeitet bekommen es wird vielleicht anders sein als vorher,
richtig richtig glück haben dann ist.
Neunzig prozent wieder so wie vorher beim richtig glück haben aber vielleicht werden wir uns auch auf eine dauerhafte virus bedrohung hier einstellen müssen,
weil das ding mutiert.
Nochmal sich gegen gegenmaßnahmen sozusagen wert wir da wieder gegen vorgehen müssen et cetera pp also kann ja alles passieren müssen wir nicht.
Nochmal nochmal vielleicht zwei zwei positive dinge und ich habe in vorbereitung zur sendung in mein tagebuch geguckt dass ich für so eine art ich jetzt jeden tag aber zu einer art börsen tagebuch,
ich habe mal geguckt was ich mit mir zu zwei zur finanzkrise zweitausendacht aufgeschrieben habe.
Ich habe mir aufgeschrieben in einer krise neigen wir dazu kurzfristig zu denken und negative trends die zukunft vorzuschreiben dekorieren dabei positive qualitäten von uns menschen wie anpassungsfähigkeit stärke innovationskraft und so weiter und ich glaube,
das passiert jetzt gerade auch das tun wir drei auch gerade und ich glaube dass ich vieles in der zukunft viel schneller und positiv verändern wird als als wir uns das irgendwie gerade vorstellen,
was ich gemacht habe ist und das ist unter uns finanzleuten ja so ein der der guru unser held wollen buffet ich habe auch mal seinen letter nochmal reingucken den er zweitausendacht geschrieben hat auch zur finanzkrise.
Und er hat auch nochmal gesagt dass im schnitt ungefähr alle zehn jahre und das passt ja jetzt ungefähr plus minus man einen starken preisrückgang mit seiner aktie also workshop dabei rechnen muss das war fünfundsiebzig gewesen siebenundachtzig zweitausendacht,
mit kurs rutschen von minus siebenunddreißig prozent und teilweise von minus neunundfünfzig prozent und er sagte jedes mal spürt die anleger große unsicherheit und das war genau der zeitpunkt wo er angefangen hat zu investieren.
Man hat mich dann jahre später gesehen was du dich dann der gewinn daraus war das immer fantastische phase bei einem einzusteigen also diese beiden dinge nochmal kombiniert ich glaube wir dürfen es nicht zu negativ sehen ich glaube auch jetzt das hat mir auch im vorgespräch gehabt ist glaube ich ein sehr guter zeitpunkt für alle.
Geld in irgendeiner form an den börsen zu investieren in aktien zu investieren und ich glaube dass man da ja also entweder geht die welt unter dann ist das geld.
Das entweder geht die welt unter dann ist das geld egal oder aber man legt jetzt den grundstein für für sein vermögen und meine grundstein für vermögen das wird halt in der in der schwersten krise gemacht nicht erst in fünf jahren,
unser wenn es nur ein etf sparplan mit fünfundzwanzig euro ist weil ich weiß auch dass menschen da draußen gibt die selbst diese fünfundzwanzig euro nicht über haben das ist mir schon bewusst aber zumindest die die es über haben die sollten zumindest darüber nachdenken.
Bei the street ist das glaube ich ne.
So sieht's aus kaufen wir die kanonendonners.
Naja okay daniel vielen dank für den beitrag so.
Gerne übrigens die gesellschaftlichen veränderungen die haben wir nochmal bei uns im podcast wenn da jemand reinhören.
Ja du darfst mal für deinen podcast mal werbung machen an dieser stelle das haben wir nämlich noch gar nicht erwähnt.
Das ist nicht die sache ist die der podcast mit der these,
geht das so ein altes konzept mal zurück was schirmacher mir mal nachgehen nahegelegt hat damals er sagte die fähigkeit analytischen wie ich den unternehmen beurteile soll ich nochmal auf die gesellschaft anwenden und das ist so ein bisschen genau der hintergrund dass wir versuchen.
Gesellschaftliche phänomene wahrzunehmen und wer ist denn der profiteur davon und.
Wir haben sie natürlich keine volumen also wir haben keine ahnung von dem virus aber wir sehen natürlich veränderungen in der gesellschaft und klar überlegen natürlich jetzt auch dann wer ist da der profiteur von was wir in den nächsten folgen auch tun werden.
Genau und ansonsten leute ihr wisst schon kaufen kaufen kaufen natürlich erst nach dem jahr euren dauerauftrag netzpolitik eingerichtet hat aber danach könnt ihr sofort loslegen.
Wir können noch ein kleines spielchen machen wir alle drei legen jetzt geld in meinem etf an und mit dem gewinn der nach drei vier jahren da rauskommt machen wir ein hörer treffer und gibt's freibier und grillwurst.
Hab ich mal gespannt wie groß das.
Nee ich würde sagen wir machen hier wir machen hier ein rendite versprechen das ganze einfach mit einem mit einem mit einem fixen sparplan.
In die metaebene haben wir auf jeden fall die beste rendite liebe hörerinnen und hörer.
Die wette gilt.
Sehr schön.
Jut brauchen wir schluss machen.
Würde ich sagen ja.
Gut vielen dank daniel.
Daniel vielen dank und ich danke an dieser stelle noch kurz lukas und andreas und einer unbekannten person.
Genau ich danke auch allen anderen weitgehend unbekannten personen die daueraufträge nicht studieren oder vielleicht in diesen zeiten auch noch aufstocken,
aber jetzt haben wir wirklich genug über geld hin und her geredet trotzdem schön hier mal wieder ein bisschen auf die metaebene höhe gegangen zu sein
und ja dann machen wir nächstes mal wieder machen wir wieder netzpolitik oder.
Und grund- und freiheitsrechte.
All das genau machen wir nächste mal bis dann tschüss.
Alles klar tschau tschau.
Tschüss.